um you talk about how you took a four or
five year break from music uh as far as
like just having that be like your main
focus yeah um i always think it's like
you as somebody who doesn't get enough
flowers for just kind of like your
legacy like some of the records you've
put out some of the bodies of work
you've had and like just in general
do you feel like that four to five years
was necessary even though it might have
maybe hurt your place in the game
yeah definitely it was necessary for me
it was necessary for
my personal growth again um it was also
necessary for me to like not
attack like attach my value to
[Music]
success
or or whatever success is perceived to
be by people you know for me i redefined
what success was for me so success for
me was a healthy mind a healthy spirit
you know what i'm saying success is very
subjective man longevity bro
let's be let's keep it a honey like
we we live you know these lives you know
we have 24 hours in a day
you know um when you become an artist
there's so many other things that people
don't realize the responsibilities and
the stress that come with being an
artist like it really can take a toll on
you so if you're not like preparing
yourself for the next 10 years
then i don't think like for me i i feel
like artists have to learn how to
prepare themselves for the next 10 15
years like what's your retirement plan
like you feel me because like
you know this [ __ ]
music come and go i've been blessed
enough to come out in a time where like
music was really about classics you know
what i'm saying this is true people be
like yo
when you are you making a comeback it's
like nah it's not really a comeback let
me love you streams
two million times every day and a half
that's so crazy you feel me how do i
breathe straight like my hits
still go crazy for sure as if they just
came out so it's like for me it's just
more of a rebranding thing than it is a
coming back thing yeah i think like you
said man i think like when we think of
success like success is defined to
everyone's personal
like happiness yeah life for sure
i'm not you know i think that there's
like if you if you're
if you're um
in the industry and you're known for
being an artist there is definitely
um
certain milestones certain milestones
are certain things that comes with like
somebody can
view your success as an artist in terms
of the numbers and in terms of like this
there's no you know but in terms of like
personal success that's that's something
that you
have to that has to be your own personal
virtue you know what i'm saying but um
i think that success comes with
happiness comes with success to me it's
like if i'm not happy
whether it's a relationship a business
um working partnership like if we're not
enjoying the process of this and i think
the pandemic showed us all that like yo
are you enjoying what you do like who
are you really outside of just what the
world knows you for or your public
perception a lot of that [ __ ] went away
during the day yeah you know so so
success
has to go for me true success has to run
hand in hand with happiness and and
peace
and um enjoying what you're doing
enjoying the process whether you're
making money or are you are you enjoying
what you do while you're making this
bread like you know what i'm saying